foreign
Kansas City hey Mark welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thank you both appreciate it I'll get
right to it
okay I've been uh I think what you call
dumb about five years ago
five years ago I co-signed on a mortgage
for my ex-wife and yep she was my
ex-wife at the time
fast forward a couple years I've learned
that she owes the IRS over 100 Grand and
they've since filed a lien on her
property probably in the last year and a
half to two years
so
um somehow she manages a little check to
check and the kids are going to start
falling off from child support and I
don't know how she's going to make it
and what implications that has for me in
this whole scenario
wow
yeah you're right dude you stepped in it
oh man I'm sorry
um
okay first I have to know what possibly
what story could possibly be told to you
to make you co-sign for your ex-wife
because by definition she's X
you're not gonna make me tell you this I
just the three yeah the three kids and
the the violin was playing in the
background I think
maybe caught me at a weak moment
sweet Mark now I'd heard
yeah you thought you were doing good you
thought you were doing good for you good
for your kids and she's the mother of
your children okay we'll try to cut you
some slack here
I appreciate it we'll still we'll still
put the action in the dumb column I
agree with your opening statement all
right anyway now we're there what do we
do uh no sense in throwing all the
everybody under the bus let's just keep
rolling what what do we do what do we do
what do we do okay she cannot refinance
and get you off because she has an IRS
lien unless you can get the IRS to
subordinate and with it being such a
large lien there's a possibility they
would subordinate she would have to
qualify for the mortgage on her own and
the IRS would have to agree to
subordinate meaning they agree to stay
in second position and put a new
mortgage in front of them instead of the
old one I've gotten them to do that in
negotiations it's rather lengthy but
she's got to qualify and it doesn't
sound like she can
not a chance
now selling the house is very very
difficult
um however uh the first mortgage is how
much
460. what's the house worth
I think at best 8.50
when do the kids age out of Child
Support
over the next three years
how much money do you have
uh 1.6
half of that's in retirement
okay
um
when I do something stupid and it costs
me money
I call it stupid tax
uh boy I've heard this before
[Laughter]
so I think you're getting ready to write
a stupid tax check at some point in this
equation now sooner rather than later
later rather than sooner depending on
when the kids age out and all that kind
of stuff but let's pretend they aged out
and there's no more need for you to have
violins in the background uh in terms of
her having this house I would walk over
and say I will give you
ten thousand dollars
if you'll sell your house
and then she sells the house she has
enough equity to pay off the IRS and she
gets she gets rid of the mortgage that
has you on it and then she goes and gets
her another house with the equity she
gets sure than me too that's great she
gets rid of you you get rid of her this
was the original intent of the whole
thing until you stepped in it
um yeah and you wouldn't push her to
sell the house now because well I mean
she could but I think it's going to be a
harder sale and plus you you did this
partly to give your kids a better place
to live and they're not aged out yet
right
that's correct so I mean if you do it
today you're putting the kids in the
street too
correct but she could make the move
today I don't know what mindset she's in
but I'll tell you what she's probably
got she got an IRS breathing down her
neck she's got a house that she's
wondering how she's going to be able to
afford when child support drops off
she's worried about this stuff deep down
not on top of not on top like you are
but even she feels it in the tenseness
across her shoulder blades because she's
human we all can see the truck coming
towards our car right
yes and so she sees that and she does
not know how to get out have y'all had
any conversations about it Mark you and
you and very little you haven't been the
greatest Communicator that probably
surprises you but no but not very much
okay okay well part of that is she's
she's buried under stress and it's got
It's got part of your name on it yeah so
you know I would just sit down if you
can have a conversation if it's possible
and just say hey here's an idea and I'll
help you one last time if you sell the
house you get rid of me and the IRS and
you've got enough equity to go get you
another house
you can either do that now or you could
do it later and I'll write a check to
help you do this
because it gets me off the mortgage
because it's worth 10 grand or 20 grand
if you got 1.6 to get rid of this
contingent liability this cosigned
liability because if this thing goes
belly up she's going to get foreclosed
on and you're going to get to ride with
her
because you can't stop the Foreclosure
because you can't you can't force the
sale of the house the only good news in
this whole story is also has enough
equity to take out the IRS
it needs to be sold for her sake yeah
and it blesses you in the process
that's right so let's dangle some kind
of a carrot that causes that to happen
now or when the kids age out I don't
care which but
sooner the better because I gotta feel
and this is
it'll be a relief to her if she
understands whether she is conscious of
it or not she's carrying a load of
stress oh yeah Dr chandeloni talks about
that when we're in debt the this lack of
agency this lack of autonomy because
we're a slave that that
she's carrying the weight of that when
she's I mean he said and she's living
paycheck to paycheck anyways
and then you have a lien on the house
from the
one on your on your list of things to do
is to deal with the KGB I mean the IRS
it's just they are not this is not a
creditor you want to have okay no the
penalties the interest it's just out of
control their power is virtually
unlimited uh in this case I've seen a
few times not often that they'll
actually come in and force the sale of
the house to get their money to get the
money um and if she doesn't do something
with this lean eventually they'll get
around to that now they're not exactly
efficient but eventually they'll get
around to it so but the stress of this
is just on everybody so here's an
interesting thing now now you know we we
poked it Mark a little bit we also gave
him a little bit of a break and you know
we kind of laughed with him and at him
both in his presence so it's all okay
right but the uh because we've all done
stupid stuff but the the thing is this
there's a couple of things here that you
can take away as a money principle
sometimes
doing what it feels like is
you're you're trying to help someone but
you're doing it in such an illegitimate
way you end up actually hurting the
person you're trying to help
co-signing does that every time
there's actually a proverb in the Bible
that says only a fool cosigns for
another the Contemporary English version
says if you co-sign for someone else
you're stupid
it's in the Bible okay so I mean and so
co-signing is an illegitimate way to
help someone meaning if you don't have
the money for junior to get a car and
you co-sign for junior to get a car you
are stepping in it for sure when it's
your ex-wife you're stepping in it up to
your knees you need boots for this walk
unbelievable man you know for sure and
sometimes when you give someone some
money even without a debt or without a
co-signing involved uh what and and it's
enabling the buy something they can't
afford the behavior right right then
you've the you know my well my my
daughter needed a house and I gave her
the down payment and now she's got a
house payment that she can't afford how
many times does that happen like every
week on the show a well-meaning parent
so you got to be careful what you're
participating in because enablers are
the nicest people in the world they're
sweet people that don't know how to say
no and then they enable bad behavior and
so while you were trying to be a help
you end up being a curse in their life
with money you had dollar signs on it
too curse with dollar signs yeah and
mark That's not aimed at you that's just
aimed at all the things all of us have
done like what you did